bonjour gérald olivier merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur arte france on le
disait 1 130 millions plus de 130
millions de vaccinés aujourd'hui aux
états unis
comment expliquer déjà le succès de
cette campagne de vaccination alors
bonjour d'abord il faut rendre à césar
ce qui appartient à césar c'est à dire
que si le vaccin aujourd'hui est
disponible aux etats-unis c'est parce
que le président preuve l'année dernière
a lancé une opération qui en anglais
s'appelait web speed et que l'on peut
traduire par la vitesse de l'éclair
opération dans laquelle il avait demandé
est passé des contrats avec un certain
nombre de doses de pharmacists pour
justement un trouver un vaccin de
manufacturer un vaccin dans des délais
records et lui avaient passé un contrat
pour quelques 800 millions de doses
il avait passé avec pfizer avec modern
art avec astrazeneca même avec sanofi ne
se ment pas ne sachant pas qui aurait un
taxane premier est en fait ces failles
there et modern and heroes produisent
pas que ça le premier et 400 millions de
doses avait déjà été produites avant la
fin décembre 2020 d'ailleurs aux jo bats
et donne lui même a été vaccinée ainsi
que sa vice présidente
kamala harris et depuis le principe le
gouvernement américain a racheté 200
millions de doses a failli there et âme
à derna puisque ce sont les deux vaccins
qui sont les plus répandus et qui sont
les plus diffusés aux états unis et la
campagne de vaccination à laquelle on
assiste basse le résultat en fait d'une
opération qui a été annoncé il ya un an
et dont une grande partie du crédit
revient au président trump il est
d'ailleurs un petit peu dommage que le
président par eden dans son allocution
le mois dernier au mois de mars n'est
pas reconnu cette dette pourrait-on dire
envers son prédécesseur au nom de
l'unité nationale parce que c'est vrai
que trump depuis le début avait
misez sur un vaccin et qu'on voit
aujourd'hui
et bien que cette approche produit des
résultats
alors on a vu dans ce sujet tout à
l'heure à de nombreux états dans de
nombreux états les deux justement envoyé
ne trouve souvent pas preneur et sont
parfois je t'aide ont gâché qu'est ce
qui explique selon vous ce gâchis alors
il ya deux éléments à prendre en contre
le premier malheureusement est un
élément politique
rappelons que l'année 2020 est une année
de campagne électorale et qu'au nom de
la campagne électorale certaines
personnes notamment un madame carol
harris qui est aujourd'hui vice
présidente avait répondu à des
journalistes qu'elle ne ferait pas
confiance à un vaccin produit sous
administration troque donc un certain
doute a été mise en place dès le début
sur l'efficacité du vaccin
ça c'est une première chose et puis une
deuxième chose qui est en train de se
produire aux états unis c'est que les
américains se demandent quand est ce que
l'on pourra retrouver une vie normale
et l'idée c'était qu'une fois qu'on est
vacciné et bien on peut retirer le
masque on peut retourner au restaurant
on peut aller au cinéma on peut se
retrouver dans les stades
on peut faire des barbecues en famille
on peut retrouver une vie normale
est ce que les médecins américains sont
en train de dire aujourd'hui c'est que
vous êtes vacciné mais ça ne veut pas
dire que vous ne pouvez pas attrapé le
virus
si vous la trappe et vous aurez sans
doute une version considérablement moins
je dirais nuit il que si vous n'aviez
pas été vaccinés mais il faut préserver
les gestes barrière il faut préserver la
distanciation sociale on ne peut pas
encore retourner à une vie normale et
les américains se disent pas si le fait
d'être vaccinées ne change rien pourquoi
se faire vacciner
ça c'est l'autre chose qu'il peut
prendre en considération et puis un
troisième élément qu'il ne faut pas
oublier c'est qu'aux états unis
le coc vide n'a pas du tout touché le
territoire de manière équitable
vous avez des centres de foyers des
clusters beaucoup plus importants que
d'autres là
en citer deux populations joue une part
majeure dans la façon dont la pandémie a
pu se répandre new york a été beaucoup
plus touchés que le mississippi où que
le montana et à partir de là il y à une
urgence à se faire vacciner quand on est
new yorkais que l'on ne peut pas
ressentir si l'on habite le montana où
l'idaho où un autre état rural
donc il faut tenir compte de ces
disparités géographiques
geraldo nivet très rapidement avant de
avant de se quitter vous parliez tout à
l'heure de kloster on voit en ce moment
à une recrudescence du nombre de cas aux
états unis malgré cette campagne de
vaccination comment l'expliquer
justement lors il ya une recrudescence
il faut quand même tenir compte des ddd
chiffres au mois de janvier
jamais les chiffres tout à l'heure on en
était à 300 milles parfois trois cent
mille nouveaux cas tous les jours trois
cent mille cas aujourd'hui on est tombé
à peu près à 50 mille nouveaux cas donc
on a quand même une division par six par
rapport à la période avant vaccin en ce
qui concerne les décès on observe
exactement la même chose des états unis
à un moment on était à quatre mille
décès tous les jours je crois que hier
on en était à 3 cents même si le chiffre
est un petit peu plus bas puisqu'il ya
moins de décès qui sera porté le
dimanche que les autres jours de la
semaine
mais il ya quand même eu une baisse
considérable par contre c'est vrai qu'on
arrive à une sorte de plancher qui est
de 500 décès tous les jours et 50 mille
nouveaux cas donc le virus continue de
se répandre mais on est quand même très
très largement en dessous des chiffres
qui étaient ceux de l'automne et avant
la campagne de vaccination
merci beaucoup gérald olivier d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur arte france
rappelle et que vous êtes chercheur à
l'ipp ce et journaliste analyste
franco-américain merci beaucoup